a huge 200 foot diameter balloon if
two-thirds the width of a football field
it's a big ass balloon up at 60 70 000
feet well above the civil aviation
flying Zone well above that so it wasn't
in anybody's way but we didn't put it up
there who did it maybe we could have
shot it down over Alaska but you want to
learn about it you see something you
don't understand you say enemy kill it
kill it or say hmm if I watch this and
let's say it is your enemy I'll see what
the enemy might be up to try to gather
as much information as you can I think
it's important to resist the urge that
just because we don't haven't figured
out what it is yet that it must be
aliens from another planet
foreign
[Music]